this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app do you
want to get paid five dollars and also
give five dollars to charity I think you
probably do you should um you want to
buy and sell Bitcoin instantly or get
your paycheck deposited right to the app
think you should its 2018 think that's
how it should be so that's what the cash
app will let you do you download the
free cash app for iOS or Android now
it's a number one finance app in the App
Store so do it
this episode is also brought to you by
blue apron blue apron is the leading
meal kit delivery service in the US when
you cook with blue apron you're not just
having burgers for dinner you're making
short rib burgers with a hoppy cheddar
sauce on a pretzel bun blue apron is
treating my listeners to their first
three meals a $30 value with your first
order if you visit blue apron home /
Congrats so check out this week's menu
and get your $30 off with Free Shipping
at buuck bring calm / Congrats blue
apron a better way to cook is in
February I don't know what what is the
date dude it is the it is February yeah
it's we did want to show in February so
whatever you know I just go by the I fly
by the seat of my pants man you think I
give a what day it is nah but let's
take care of some business before we
even start this life cult
meeting Follow the Leader my new tour we
announce the first leg on Instagram and
Twitter and split cider announced it
actually they broke it first and you can
buy tickets and I am going to the it's
it's on presale now or tomorrow and it
goes on sale for the general public on
Friday and these are the cities for the
first leg of the tour Tallahassee
Florida Orlando Florida Charleston South
Carolina Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
um Dayton Ohio Huntsville Alabama
Nashville Tennessee Denver Colorado and
Boise Idaho for some reason so that's
where we're going first leg of the tour
I'm adding many cities everyone saying
what about Chicago what about Toronto
what about Ottawa I'm common move common
daddy's coming to Seattle
daddy's gonna come everywhere
don't worry Vancouver don't worry Austin
Texas don't worry Dallas we gonna do it
so I see all your comments and thank you
and and I'm gonna and I can I can't wait
man all new material for men on fire and
it's a place for us babies to unite and
come come together and enjoy enjoy the
time or whatever the I don't know
child off the sentence but you guys I
was in Canada for a week solid you know
when people say man I was there for a
good week I don't like when they add
good for no reason a week is a week if
it was good or bad it's the same amount
of time that man he was sitting there
for a good 20 minutes before he said
something you know what 20 minutes
doesn't make it longer it makes it mate
you're trying to make it seem like it's
longer by adding good - it wasn't longer
20 minutes is 20 minutes baby 20 minutes
is 20 minutes if you're just sitting
there and 20 minutes is 20 minutes if
you're playing volleyball it's
it boy he was there for a good hour and
a half or just an hour and a half yeah
didn't too many adjectives yeah turn
around so I was in Canada for a good
week I was there from I went Monday to I
got back Sunday so not a good week so
six days so completely lied to babies
but I was I was there I shot a little I
shot an episode of the good doctor and
then I went to North Battleford which
many you guys don't know where that is
because you're not Canadian
and even Canadians maybe not its way up
there man
it's like in the Northern Territory or
some and I was making fun of the
place because dude how much artwork can
you have with an eagle flying having a
trout in its talons dude it it's a
Canadian the artwork they can't it's not
artwork if there is there isn't if if
you paint something in in North
Battleford you have to also have include
an eagle with a trout in its talons
otherwise it's not art swear to God you
draw a draw a portrait of a
woman and people be like well I was not
recognised as art unless there's an
eagle in the background carrying
a trout in its talons hey Canada we get
it okay um but I was in North Battleford
and first of all I got there and when I
got there I show I got there a day early
oh my man I mean dude these people
have happy lives and they're there and
it's great and god bless him really and
and really nice people and and it's
pretty man I mean it's really pretty
there the snow was so white I didn't I
forgot how white snow is man
I mean snow is whiter than Ryan
Seacrest dude it is blinding dude you
just walk outside and it here's the
other thing too oh man I have so many
things I want to talk about okay look
let me just start this off by saying if
it's below 30 degrees now let's do 25
degrees now that's Fahrenheit because
I'm American I don't know what the
it is Celsius and I know Americans are
the only ones who uses Fahrenheit and
but whatever it is everyone when I
was going to North Battleford
it was negative five degrees okay now of
course eat my naturally eat my
right and I put it on Instagram and
people were like way to get to Calgary
it's it's colder than that
and okay and then when I put it on
Calgary
it was way it was like negative
something and then in and they were like
wait till you get to Winnipeg which is I
guess the coldest let me tell you
something if it's below 25 degrees
fahrenheit it's the same amount of cold
I don't give a if it's 20 because I
was in mini hide to connect in
Minneapolis or if you were rob
gronkowski mini annapolis idiot
he said mini annapolis dude Rob
Gronkowski said mini annapolis he said
Freeza Freeza mini annapolis ass is
stupid the stupidest hey man got some
concussions how about that carry
yourself but it's it's called you don't
get you don't say oh yeah way to get to
win it's all cold you can't go outside
you go outside and thirty seconds you're
just like oh let me get the inside
21 to go Mini Mini Annapolis was 21
degrees Freeza Freeza mini Annapolis was
21 degrees and it was too cold and I was
I was and and and guess what North
Battleford
dude when I went to Winnipeg it was the
biggest you temperature of all time
it was one degree yeah you you know
one degree it's cuz you got to
change it from degrees to degree you
don't say one degrees you know it's the
biggest you temperature hey what
hey what's the what's the temperature
one am at imagine in Winnipeg that's
what it was hey what what's the
temperature it's one it's one yum it is
one degree there's yum it is one degree
yum dude that's gross his
and so cold is cold now
I got to the show on in North Battleford
why'd I go and and the opener I show up
in the openers like hey man so uh what's
your name and I'm like Oh Chris D'Elia
and he's like oh cool
and I was like first of all no me first
II in the comedy business no me first of
all I I know I'm not I mean there are so
many people that don't know who I am
I'd like to think if you're a comedian
you know who I am okay
that being said even if that's not the
truth if you were hired to open for me
Google may okay he literally came up and
said what's her name this guy's a
comedian he's been a comedian for
20-some years
okay now granted he's a comedian in
North Battleford he's a comedian in
Saskatoon they changed that name
Saskatoon is it a cart - ISM hey
that sound like a mascot yeah let's
bring out the Saskatoon yeah yes it's
called yes that one fire is tight typing
out is that how you say that yeah that's
how you say it Saskatoon Saskatchewan is
that is the province or whatever
Saskatoon is the city and one fire
continues to be one fire anyway uh so he
was like what's your name and I was like
oh I'm crystal ears I got cool and I was
like all right cool and we were just
chilling like hanging out and he was in
the green room and and then he was
like and then he asked me uh and then he
was like so uh so what do you so know
this is the first question he asked me
so what kind of music you listen to and
I'm like I said I literally said what
kind of music do I listen to and he said
yeah like what do you do and I was like
I don't know I kind of just chill and
like I listen to hip-hop
and he was like oh and then he said so
what do you so what's your show like and
I said um I just kind of go out there
and tell jokes you never saw my stuff
and he says oh you're a comedian and I
said yeah
you're opening for me right and he said
I thought you were a musician or
something Google me
I wasn't even offended I don't look I
don't get offended at that but like
no homework he was like oh they just
asked me to open he was like they
literally just asked me and I don't know
I did just ask me I said when did they
ask you he said two days ago had time I
said oh where you're from he's at
Saskatoon ah
that's two hours from here ah google it
on the way he was like oh you're a
comedian oh I'm gonna stay and watch
your show pay for it now dude and and he
was like I'm sorry man I don't know I
was like dude I don't give a like
whatever and then after the show he's
like dude I've seen you I've seen you
I've seen you I've seen the drunk girl
stuff and I was like okay it's like I'm
sorry I don't I was like I don't give a
what but like for your own sake
know the business a little bit you know
it was really funny I mean nice enough
the nice nicest it wasn't malicious
or anything I liked the guy
[Music]
yeah and and was like I seen you I see
the drunk stuff which means he was only
googling me during my show which means
it's disrespectful watch it but it was
funny and then so afterwards so so let
me tell you let me give you a little
background about North Battleford so
North Battleford a lot of people in
Canada know about this I don't know if
people in America or around the world
know about this but they're going
through something that's really
a dramatic thing so a white a white guy
shot an indigenous guy that I broke in
to apparently was on his property or
broke into his house or something like
that but the white guy shot the
indigenous guy in his head so they had a
whole they had the the the what he call
it the the trial during the time I was
there like the week of that time and so
you know the a lot of people are saying
well he shot him in the head it wasn't
self-defense it was sounds a little iffy
it sounds shitty it sounds like
he just killed the guy and then a lot of
people are saying well he was on his
property and this and that he was
threatening him so you know that that
little law is you can shoot the guy I
don't really know much about the case so
don't bombard me with facts
about it I'm simply giving you a little
background so I can tell you this story
when I got when I what happened with me
when I was there I don't know what's
right and what's wrong in this case I
didn't really look it up because I'm an
idiot
all right but when I got back to the
hotel after the show I get there
and the manager was like oh hey um can I
talk to you for a second
and I was like sure and by the way this
is what this place is like think Twin
Peaks okay that's what it's like you've
got people they're so friendly but it's
also s super weird cuz it gets dark at
3:00 and the Sun comes out at known
there's three hours of daylight man you
can't there's nothing there like I was
like is there a coffee somewhere and
they're like oh we could make some for
you like as their Starbucks somewhere oh
there's a there's a Tim Hortons down the
service road hey man if you're saying
service road to me it's too far the
are you plopping down settling off a
service road look it over
hey use your getaway sticks and park it
in saskatoon
ice I heard a girl call her legs getaway
sticks the other day and I
wanted to sit on a dildo get her what
sticks I wanted to sit on a dildo so
something else was happening she's
calling out people on me too if she was
like look if a guy's sexually assaulting
you
I'm gonna use my getaway sticks and
leave the situation I almost drove
directly to a sex shop bought a dildo
drove home parked it none on my
chair and bounced up and down on it so I
didn't have to think about someone
saying getaway sticks not ironically so
I get back to the hotel it's
like a fifty second walk from the casino
to the hotel I'm frozen
coz it's one all right it's actually
less than one but one I was you know
saying it again because it was funny
okay so I get back to the hotel and the
guy says oh um so uh hey can I talk to
you for a second and I said sure what's
up and he comes up real close to me like
I'm talking about if he was any closer
he'd be me all right and he's and he
talks to me and his breath was good as
I think I feel like them when you
get north those probably I
know honestly in Northern Territory I
guarantee those bearded like nice
pasty white I bet
they have good his breath and this
guy did he was the beginning of it so he
comes up to me and he says do you know
what's going on around the north
battleford right now and I was like yeah
I know a little bit but he says ok so
you know about the trial and what
happened and how the guy got shot yeah
and I said I dunno yeah yeah so it's a
crazy time uh he said ok so
the trials going on and um just to let
you know nothing nothing is it's all
good but the the jurors on the trial are
on your floor and they're staying on
your floor and there are sheriffs out
there and there will be sheriffs out
there in your hallway but they're on the
other side so don't worry it's totally
safe okay but just letting you know that
the jurors to the case where a guy shot
another guy and people are thinking that
it's very racist and there will
definitely be death threats to the I
mean I didn't say this part but I mean
like what am I in a John Cusack
movie
oh I'm Jeff so I looked at my own oh I'm
John Cusack like I'm all of a sudden I
did a show for some guys for 400
people at a casino and now all of a
sudden I manage Enoch I'm in movie dudes
is how gene gene Hackman picks a movie
hey gene Hackman's agent hey gene hey
how's it going hey so they want you to
do another movie
how cool is it about a juror is it about
a jury no it's like thinking if you'd
like to make a call please hang up and
try again
message see five remember that do
you remember that when you used to
leave the phone off the hook for too
long and Millennials don't owe this
barely but it's like well I mean I'm a
millennial I guess but like
right before me dude with no cell phones
usually hang up the phone and you leave
it off the hook and it would all of a
sudden they would go Aang Aang Aang Aang
Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang Aang so
you knew it was off the hook
and then you pick it up and if you left
it it would go and Aang Aang Aang Aang
message c25 please hang up and or some
who was that guy message
c25 so now I'm in a Twin Peaks
Lodge and the juror for the trial of the
century in North Battleford the jury is
there and I'm like I'm gonna get
murdered dude anyway it didn't happen
and oh and then the guy says oh by the
way when are you leaving tomorrow and I
said oh really early and he said oh okay
I was gonna ask you if you wanted to go
ice fishing
ha ha snorin I said oh yeah he said yeah
I wanted to see if you wanted to go ice
fishing gets warm in there huh I said
what and he said it gets super warm in
the cabin there in that little shed put
on a fire and you just sit there nice
fish it's to you it's t-shirt weather ah
snore then hey man are you up penguin
hey dude real quick are you Santa hey I
got a quick question are you three feet
tall the are you doing up here
use your getaway sticks I was like ah
part of me honestly and I know you know
me babies I know you know ah dude you
probably would never go ice fishing I
swear to God if I was there a full day I
would have went that's so so weird and
it's so not me I would have had to go
and then he was showing me pictures he
was like oh check out these pictures huh
look look I want to show you what I
called last time and they pulls up
picture I swear to god it's a chick with
her cleavage out and he was like look
that's the wrong picture and I I was
like I don't he by the way wasn't
embarrassed at all
well he wasn't embarrassed at all but
just to make sure I just said I it's
cool I got those pictures to men
oh yeah anyway and he kept swiping swipe
and swipe in Hey Dude what kind of
sociopath
picks up their phone to show you the
pictures and doesn't hide it first and
get to the picture and then show you you
know all the crazy screenshots
and screen grabs screen grabs I got my
photo deck did I got pictures of
like crazy taking pictures of my
taint you know sending them to
Bryan Callen come on and this guy oh oh
I'm sorry wrong picture just some
titties out there's the fish hey
you know what he is honestly the most
normal man in the world that's who he
was you know how they used they had that
he's the most interesting man in
the world
he Jack Bauer when he was 12 on
the dough sake this guy's
the most normal man in the world he'll
pull up his camera roll and it'll show
you he'll you'll see the pictures that
he asked to be sent from a girl in
Saskatoon and swiped right by it and
show you his ice fish he caught
he's the most normal man in the world in
a good way he's got a family
he lives happily he warns you about he
warns you about a jury stay stayin on
the fourth floor he warns you he's a
good guy he'll make you coffee if you
need it
he's the most normal man in the world he
were guess what he wore a blue
button-down and khakis that's what he
wore of course he did the nicest kind of
where I want to hang out that
I would have a nice Q
fishing with him for sure
anyway so I got through that did the
show it was a little weird it was all
set up like a wedding banquet it
was fine I think they had a good time I
had a fine time it was good I kind of
just trailed off and did what I did I
did what I do sometimes but and then on
the show and then I went to Calgary
again I went to the same spot that two
shows this time that one show last time
dad come I want the world to know and
make it so I'm coming up yeah
I could ask him how he wants each cut of
his body to be done and label it for him
with a black marker YUM oh hell we live
in hell dude this is from Episode a
throwback from two episodes ago when I
was talking about the episode and sword
in the scale when the kit when
when the guys are talking about eating
children this is what the guy says I
could ask him how he wants each cut of
his body to be done and label it for him
with a black marker YUM
I mean the yum dude I could ask him dude
how he wants to be label each of his
body part and how he wants to be done
yum yum Oh babies Oh babies Oh babies
mm-hmm you guys here we go
Square cash look if you haven't heard
we're switching to the cash app it's the
simplest way to pay people back friends
family very thoughtful wedding guests
anyone really setting and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly into
your bank account in just a few seconds
you know the cash app lets you do way
more than that too now you can even buy
and sell Bitcoin instantly get your
paycheck deposited right to the app pull
money out of the ATM with the free
custom cash card or use it to spend
anywhere you like you really won't find
a more useful finance app out there and
that's Chris D'Elia telling you that and
of course when you download the cash app
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund it's great I use it I've switched
over to it I use the cash app for mostly
everything and I like using it and when
somebody doesn't have have it I make
them get it cuz I'm stalling and then
it's easier to just like pay people back
you know you go to dinner with friends
and then you afterwards you sell let me
just catch up you the money for the
sushi it's great
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now look you heard about clip
you have if you're a baby if you're a
person with a mouse
which yar unless you're neo in that
scene in the matrix when he's like
mm-hmm it's likely that you don't brush
your teeth
for a full two minutes change your brush
on time or brush twice a day
clip gets that so they designed the
perfect electric toothbrush the quip is
the new electric toothbrush that packs
just around a mind of amount of
vibrations into a slimmer design at a
fraction of the cost of bulkier
traditional electric brushes it comes
with a mount that suctions right onto
your mirror and on sticks to use the
cover look it's just it's great I use it
I have it I take it on the road it
doesn't make my gums hurt like a lot of
those other electronic electric
electronic toothbrushes it looks like
Apple designed it it's sleek it's cool
if a chick sees it she's gonna hang out
with you again it's backed by quip is
backed by a network of over 10,000
dental professionals including dentists
hygienists and dental students and it's
it starts at just $25 and right now when
you go to quit get qyp comm get clipped
comm / congrats to get your first repo
Pat pack free with equip electric
toothbrush
that's your first refill pack free at
get clip comm / Congrats spell GE t qu
IP comm / Congrats it's great delivering
a new brush head ever delivering new
brush heads every three months for just
five dollars including free shipping
worldwide so get on that guys blue apron
is the number one fresh ingredient and
recipe a delivery service in the country
I love blue apron I've been cooking with
it and I eat it it's always good it's
always different its mission is to make
incredible home cooking accessible to
everyone it is very easy if I can do it
you can do it trust me they offer three
plans the two-person meal plan serves
two people eight recipes per week choose
from that family meal plan meals that
serve for people choose from four new
recipes per week with the choice to
receive either two three or four recipes
any week and the wine plan six bottles
of wine from renowned wine makers
delivered monthly
upcoming meals are great strip steak and
potatoes and spicy maple collard greens
again hungry yet creamy fusilli boosts
bukhari pasta with fried rosemary and
walnuts what is it if you don't know
what it is you know it tastes good
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs needs and
there's no weekly commitment I get your
deliveries when you want them blue apron
is treating my listeners to their first
three meals a $30 value with your first
order if you visit blue apron dot-com /
Congrats so check out this week's menu
and get your first get your $30 off with
free shipping and blue a blue apron calm
/ Congrats blue apron a better way to
cook so I was in Canada and then I went
to so I went to I did the North
Battleford show than I did the Calgary
show and then in the Winnipeg shows and
I came back and I have never been so
happy to come back from the road it was
just too cold I don't know how they do
it man I don't know how they do it it's
so cold it's so cold but they do it and
they love it maybe it's it's it's better
that way follow the leader tour go get
your tickets
I just love LA I love it like because of
the weather people some people I get it
I get it why you don't like I get why
people don't like Los Angeles but it's
just it's just how it is every time when
I was on the fly I tell you what man
every time I sat down to eat in Canada
whatever I don't know what it is maybe
was just where I was every meal was like
and on the side bas Amati rice and I
flew home chicken ba Sumati rice
basmati rice sucks it's not good I eat
it everywhere I eat it in Winnipeg I ate
it and everything was with basmati rice
is just regular rice I know I'm not in a
BAS tamati rice dude
um I order sometimes to meals because I
don't know what I want when I'm at a
restaurant sometimes over two meals and
also let me tell you something most
portions aren't enough like we've talked
about this already on this show I have
and like when people are like oh how
much I can't remember I was like a clip
that I put out there was like how much
did you make
but like dude most of its it's like I or
sometimes were to like it when I was in
Vancouver I go to this place I get the I
got the salmon rice bowl and I would get
the pasta and I would eat that and
and here's something don't ever do
waiter if you order two meals Oh Satan
say this oh you're hungry huh
you're calling me a fat that's what
you're doing I don't need to have any
kind of cordial oh ha ha ha yeah what am
I gonna say to that yeah uh-huh
hey go get it oh you hungry huh or when
you eat and then you're done and you eat
quick and they're like oh you didn't
like it huh yeah yeah take this plate in
the kitchen oh you were hungry
huh yeah that's why I'm at a goddamn
restaurant
what's this plate still doing a front of
me I don't like when waiters do that
if I was a waiter I would act
purposely more like a robot because
that's how it should be hello how would
you like your meal
hello I am here to help you YUM then
they'd order whatever they ordered I'd
say yeah may I'll be right back with
your order and then I would be like
hello can I take your order and they'd
be like yeah sure I'll get meatloaf and
I'll say that is beautiful it comes with
a bass Omaha tea rice YUM would you like
anything else
and they'd be like yeah a coke beautiful
we have Pepsi instead would you like
Pepsi or would you like water will you
like water as well
yes YUM would you look and then have you
like hey what would you like and then
they would say I could ask him how he
wants each cut of his body to be done
and label it no that's what I would do I
was in the back in the back in the
kitchen I'd be like there ordering food
and they would say what would late what
would they like no they would say
because they wouldn't be a robot I'd be
a robot I'd be like I'll take table 9
and they'd say okay cool
and they'll be like I'll go get their
order right now and then they say ah
sounds good thanks for taking the table
and then I'd say no I'm gonna go take
their order and then they say oh cool
and then I'd say I could ask him how he
wants each cut of his body to be done
and label it for him with a black marker
yum I would say you're fired
would you like me today cable darn yeah
sure that sounds good great I could ask
him how he wants each cut of his body to
be done and label it for him with a
black marker YUM I'm going to talk to
the manager wait that's my favorite part
I could ask him besides the of his body
to be done that's besides the embody to
be done I could ask him how you want
each part of his body to be done that's
my favorite proper size the young I mean
black marker you know I don't need to be
specific just say write it on it yeah
but I don't like when when waiters do
that I have a part of my act where
I talk about how what about waiters so I
don't want to get too into it you got to
come see the follow-the-leader tour yeah
it's actually hard not it's hard to not
burn material on here when you're when
you're doing a podcast but I do come up
with a lot of material on
well not a lot but some of it like I
talk about Australia in my new Act and I
did I talk a little bit about that here
mmm
Oh first but anyway how about hangry no
you don't say hangry you say hungry
that's it dude you know what happened
first of all here's another thing too I
don't like when people people talk about
spirit animals hey no you know how many
people have how many like 16
year old girls say like oh that's my
spirit animal not about me but like I
mean they do it on me sometimes but like
just like ah my spirit animal John Mayer
is my spirit animal know John Mayer is
John Mayer
there's no such thing as a spirit animal
there's an animal and guess what there's
no such things about spirits
there's no such thing as a spirit it's
an animal that's it
I I don't you know what actually also is
like that this is what happens so much
this is what happens to me a lot people
will say ah you're literally me you have
this we have the exact same sense of
humor yeah not really you know why cuz
you're probably not that funny and you
don't have to think I'm funny but it's
what I do for a living
yeah you know I don't mean to sound
elitist but that's like me going up to
Elon Musk and saying oh dude we build
rockets the same way say yeah oh did you
ever build a rocket though oh but I'm
just talking about the way I would build
rockets though just like you we
have the same sensor it's not the same
because it's a little tricky because the
sense of humor you can have a sense of
humor without being a stand-up comedian
I get it but like all we have the same
sense of humor
like prawn not really would you talk
about robots nah nah you
wouldn't talk about robots in
front of thousands of people no really
you don't have the same sense humor
um how about that rocket launch dude
I mean Elon Musk first of all names Elon
Musk
hey he's Batman and that guy
launched a rocket and put a tesla out
orbiting the earth that's like already
that was the most classic picture like
that's the craziest classic picture and
and any and and the orbited the
earth his Tesla it's a good branding um
it's funny though cuz the car was just
like floating around it wasn't really
like like so it like had a spacesuit on
you know so Cocteau put your car
out in the heading to Mars and then what
gonna crash into Mars and it's not gonna
it's not gonna be able to drive aliens
in the back what is it Aang Aang Aang
Aang Aang who's Matt Damon on that
thing what is that Tesla yeah
yeah shrinking it all the way down to
size bring it and then but yeah that's
crazy to to have a rocket launch
into our musk how about did you guys see
the thing where it was like we're like
now of course negative shits coming out
about Elon Musk because it has to
because he's gotten too big I hate that
dude and they're just looking for
and some guy was like retweeting
this thing about this lady wrote
how she was like his starter wife and he
was like she told me on he told me while
in our first dance at our wedding he was
like just so you know I'm the alpha in
this relationship and this and that and
that in this and somebody was like hey
this is a totally weird thing
for a guy to say and it's on his first
wedding on his first dance as a at his
wedding and yeah that is a weird thing
to say but also hey chick you didn't
know this already you're a
you didn't know that this is the kind of
guy he was and then they were like oh
yeah but that's typical of South South
African culture and it's like dude you
didn't know who you were marrying dude
let me tell you something man
when I'm in a relationship with someone
I'm the alpha and she knows it
mmediately I'm not telling him
on her it's very weird that he told her
that on the wedding day but also know
that you're with a guy that builds
rockets and shoots them to Mars
the you don't think he's an alpha
and then she was like and then she was
like yeah well I would say I'm your wife
not your employee like she would say
that all the time to him because she
wouldn't let him play and he was said oh
I know if you were my employee I'd fire
you oh damn it
slam dude that's a Grand Slam he
knocked that out of the park
granted for saying it if it
happened but dude that's hilarious I
would say that in a jokey way though
yeah dude
how about the way there's rocket landed
you know that's baller gosh
you know Muskies husband-material
someone I saw someone on the other line
online the other day that said I have a
crush on Elon Musk oh really
you sad a housewife yeah oh
really I have a crush on Megan
Fox no oh the billionaire
that shoots rockets into the
plane to Mars
dude I was in when I was in Canada they
should they the nonstop curling non-stop
curling
you know what curling is I'm gonna talk
about curling in a little bit I got to
do this Beachbody on demand is an online
fitness streaming service that gives you
unlimited access to a wide variety of
highly effective world-class workouts
personalized to meet your needs it also
includes extensive nutritional content
all proven to help people achieve their
health and fitness goals
they got familiar brands on a p90x
insanity 21 day fix three-week yoga
retreat you guys got to get in shape man
don't be a fat baby right come on health
is wealth as they say even though wealth
is wealth but I can set this up in my
house you can to stream it on the Apple
TV app and get an incredible workout
right in your house just like I do I
like to focus t25 that's been my thing
it's an hour worth of intense workout in
25 minutes it's how I'm getting shredded
that's why people mistake me for Tarzan
is so much variety and Beachbody on
demand is convenient accessible on your
computer or whatever your no need to go
to a gym or a schedule class everything
is right there on your personal device
man it's so easy plus your annual
subscription is cheaper than a gym
membership Beachbody on demand has
programs for any fitness level from
starter to he-man there's over 600
different workouts so you don't get
bored if you need help finding a workout
style to match your interesting goals
you will find something there meal prep
information variety of recipes and
eating plans are all right there you
need to give this a try right now my
listeners can get a free trial
membership when you text congrats to 30
30 30 you will get full access to this
entire platform free all the workouts
and nutrition information free just text
congrats to 30 30 30
hairy's now I'm a hairy guy
but when I was I did this movie where I
had to shave my chest and my arms and
everything like that and I used Harry's
Harry's is it an all about great shave
and a fair price which is why over three
million guys were switched to Harry's
I like it because you get a good clean
shave
I shaved my chest with it and I would
never do that but I did it for a part
and it was great it got real close the
quality of the blades were great didn't
cut myself that hair came off like bud
was comfortable so Jeff and Andy these
two ordinary guys who were fed up with
getting charged an arm and a leg for
razor blades started hairy's to fix
shaving it stripped out the unnecessary
fixtures features and and the
unnecessary cost to deliver customers
one perfect razor as at an amazing price
it comes down to good blades man
Harry's owns their Factory and they're
able to deliver amazing quality blades
for just two dollars a blade compared to
four dollars or more they pay at the
drugstore and it's got a 100% quality
back guarantee a quality guarantee
Harry's is so confident that you're
going to love their blades that they'll
give you their trial shave set for free
when you sign up at Harry's com /
Congrats just pay for the shipping claim
your free trial offer from Harry's today
$13 value for free when you sign up just
cover shipping your free trial set
includes awaited economic razor handle 5
precision engineered blades with a
lubricating strip and trimmer blade rich
lathering shave gel a travel blade cover
so to get your free trial set go to
harrys.com / Congrats right now that's
harrys.com / Congrats we used it on one
fires head - and it worked he loved it
he worked one fire loves his close shave
but what was I saying I was going to
talk about before I uh
curling thanks 1 higher so I I did I I'm
sat I watched curling and guess what I
don't get it you know why cuz you're
sliding things around the ice
and it's a game where you try to they
have it at bars like the mini version
where you just what do they I
don't know what they call it but it's
like they put this sawdust down shuffle
what puck
for puck one higher and but yeah man
they do it on ice and these guys do it
and they let the thing go the
little disc and then they sweep in front
of it to let it go faster or something
and the the interesting thing about it
is it sucks fat donkey dicks
that's the interesting thing about it
and it's a huge Canadian thing that
Canadians love and there is strategy
there is a certain level of skill level
but the interesting thing about it is
that it sucks enormous donkey dicks now
that's the interesting thing about it so
uh you know a lot of guys who do it are
Canadian pasty white same there you go
there's that guys working completely
pasty white and it looks like they're
basically when that when the little puck
thing whatever you call it is going and
there it looks like they're just trying
to clean up before they it gets there
like they use brooms and they and they
sweep like I just every time I
look at that I just think I do
beforehand but there's like little snow
pellets on there or whatever the
and they're so serious doing it like
nobody's laughing when they're playing
curling which sucks if you're playing a
game smile and laugh cuz it's a game not
life you know there's a shirt out there
that says curling his life you know and
I'll use it to wipe my
with it I'll go out and buy it take a
huge dump use it to I'm
with it then wear the shirt around town
and people be like out what the
that and I'd say and they'd be like
why I say oh because they're most
interesting about the thing about
curling is it's a donkey dicks yeah I
don't I don't get it but you know I
don't get a lot of sports so I'm not the
guy right I'm not the guy I'm not the
demo there I mean look I just want fire
pulled up a shirt that says the good
life and then the three images under the
good life is one guys curling and then
it shows a beer mug and then it shows a
guy a girl doggy style hey not
the time
and imagine wearing that shirt out
imagine wearing that shirt at like
during the day like going to pick up
at your peel box just the
good life oh you like curling drinking
beer and doggy style one of
those things sucks
doggy styles cool beers cool if
you like beer I saw a guy online that
was talking about he was so passionate
about he was like I saw Game of Thrones
and I loved Game of Thrones and now I've
learned that the writers from Game of
Thrones are going to the writers from
Game of Thrones are going to start
working on the that Star Wars next Star
Wars movies right now right one hire and
and dude they were like but then I
realized that these guys were two
straight sis white guys and I would love
it if went to explore the you know he's
like black panther came out I would love
to explore you know and it was great for
African culture and I would love to have
like you know writers of color or
something you know not white guys
writing the next installment to the Star
Wars movies because I wanted to see
explore that the african-american per se
the african-american culture in the Star
Wars movies and like that
now guess what this guy was a white guy
saying this and and it's like what the
are you talking about man hey man
what the are you talking about dude
they got writers to write the show
write it there's gonna be white
guys black guys there's gonna be Indian
guys and Asian guys and there's also
gonna be aliens in the movie
okay just stop this guy
I stopped the thing about the online
is is like you're just trying to
look like a good person dude you don't
really give a you don't really give
a if you're just saying hey we need
to give more jobs to to whatever Asians
and Latinos online if you just tweeting
it you're not really doing you're
just trying to look like a good person
and get some you you
know you betta the dude
do something about it then man also it's
a Star Wars movie what I love how people
are talking about how no I didn't see it
so I could be completely off about this
but people are like oh man
it's so awesome black panther is showing
it African culture and it's like we're
talking about the movie where the guy
transforms into a panther right and
they're like it's like a thing that
everyone's talking about
and the what and then I'm like well hey
what about the movie hidden figures
nobody said anything about how I'm so
confused about this whole thing man I
don't even know how to talk about it
like I don't even know I honestly I
I got I'd I can't wait I am gonna see
black panther this week though because
it has 75 characters on it they were
talking about it on the news the other
day in Canada about how like about how
its it showed African culture and
like that and then the clips that were
showing was a guy shooting laser beams
at another guy and it was just like
hilarious I was like well this movie is
great because it shows African culture
and the clip they were showing was a guy
transforming into a a panther ish type
being and then shooting laser beams
Hey reaching also was definitely a white
person saying it these people man you
know he was throwing like bald disks at
cars that like blew the cars up and
this movie really elite African culture
is and then the guy flying through the
air shoots glowing disks at vehicles
that blow up I don't know I didn't see
the movie I mean I didn't see the movie
so I'm definitely talking out of turn
but I'll rip this Michael
basketball Jordan Michael B Jordan dude
somebody called him Michael
he's the B for basketball that like
years ago as she killed back here member
who was anyway what about the
Hashmi thing you see that thing that I
posted on an internet hated on the on
the internet on on on Instagram
it's called this device will keep your
phone calls totally private and then you
put that beign thing over your
mouth there's a device where you can put
it over your mouth it's called the hush
me and while you're talking on the phone
you can talk and it doesn't and it
muffles the sound so you can be in
public talking it is the single
ridiculous will put it on the video
podcast but and this guy is talking with
imagine having this thing you got a look
at it you look like a
stormtrooper that isn't ready yet that
like just got out of the shower and is
getting ready for the night and you put
it over your mouth and you're still
gonna put the earphones in I mean how
many accessories do you need
above your neck god damn it if you have
a hat on in earrings too and and and
here's they got two modes one mode which
is the hush me mode which it muffles
your sound and then they have another
mode that plays music out of the speaker
while you're talking so people hear the
music and not what you're saying
oh hey if you need to take a phone call
that bad and you're in public go away
walk away you know what use your getaway
sticks and walk over near a tree
goddamn it I mean come on dude what the
Yui they spent millions probably
making this stupid well definitely
making this stupid thing if I
saw a guy wearing that I'd go up and
start talking on my phone really loudly
him hush me has two modes active
and passive mode
I like the mode where you throw it in
the trash that's the third mode third
mode with passive mode hush me muffled
speech okay the decibels are reduced
from 60 decibels to 30 decibels not that
much just talk quieter people talk loud
as in active mode speakers will
play sounds that mask your speech what
are the sounds I'd love it if it was
hardcore porn just like oh yeah that was
the that's my favorite noise in
porn is when the girl has to let out how
good it feels
but like SWAT just like swallowed and
wasn't ready and and it's just like oh
yeah that's my favorite that's my
favorite that's so funny to me like yeah
that's my favorite one time I was at
Starbucks and I opened up my
laptop and porn was on and it was and it
just goes oh yeah and I closed it right
back up and left whatever bro you know
what I didn't give a you know why
cuz he's the most normal man in the
world
then I asked everybody to go ice fishing
but yeah
I mean hush me come on man hey invent
hey hey
cure cancer hush me Voice
silencer people talk loud dude people
talk too loud
man just some girl came up to me I was
in a restaurant in the mini
Annapolis frizzy frizzy mini Annapolis
Airport and this girl comes up to me I'm
just by myself and she says are you
Chris D'Elia so loud and I said yeah and
she said oh man I'm a huge fan and now
everyone's looking over and here's the
part where people look and I'm like oh
yeah it's that guy huh some people oh my
god that guy and then some people
don't even know who I am so there that's
embarrassing and she's like oh can I get
a picture and now how about now other
people who are fans look over and see oh
yeah that is Chris Lea and then they
want pictures and then more
people came up I get it it's the price
but also just talk quieter I said the
uh Austin Powers we can't
control the volume of his mouth I've
done it to people before where I'm like
oh yeah but you're too loud though I say
that and they don't know what - because
I sound nice
oh yeah but you're too loud oh yes yes
but you're too loud and then some people
are is quiet as and they've come up
to me and I say what are you saying you
got to talk louder otherwise I can't
hear you come on let's go let's go
you're a person let's do it come
on how loud you got to be this is too
loud this is too soft
get in the middle hey hey come
back what do you want what's up do you
mind if I get a picture sure you're
holding your phone no where is it oh
it's in your bag cool I'll just wait
here like a oh while you go dig for
it in your bag turn it on camera and
then look for somebody to take your
picture hey person how about when people
this happens sometimes when you're
walking across the street and they're
walking across the street towards you
and they say Oh Chris D'Elia can I get a
picture you got to come you gotta come
you gonna come on my side what are we
doing we taking a picture in the middle
of street are you coming back to my side
or am I going back to where I came from
one time a girl goes like this while
it's happening we're both doing it like
this walking this way to each other and
just uh Chris D'Elia can I get a picture
I say sure you coming to my side and she
goes uh and keeps walking how you
I'm not worth it then don't
ask use your brain it's
located four feet above your getaway
sticks and walk with me people ask for
pictures and their phones not charged
ah you know it is what it is and also
also I want you to know if you do ask
for a picture
I do love ya and I do appreciate the
support I really do I really do
every person who ever listened to my
comedy or ever listened to the podcast
or ever told their friend about
me that man
you guys are awesome you know do
a lot of jokes and up here and I
around and I'm silly all the time
but that means a lot man I love it
I love it it's coolest it
really is being a comedian that tours
and has been people show up like I think
about all the time how lucky and
fortunate I am and how cool it
is and it just makes me want to work
harder and reach more people and
you know I'm doing another tour now it's
just I try to get to the cities
I go to the city dude I go to the cities
I don't want to go to man I do that
because I want to I want to I
know there's people there that
you know ask me to come and so like I'm
going to Boise I I'm gonna Boise do it I
don't I never wanted to go to Boise uh
no knock on Boise I'm sure it's
great I just like I'm going because
look I'm going because I could have went
it somewhere else but I want to go there
because I've never been there and in
others people there that want to see me
and I like to do that I like and I cuz I
and I do that and yes I'm making money
and this is my job but I do that so I
can because I because I want to
reach I want to I want the people don't
want to see me to come see me there too
anyway um that's what's up what is this
here this thing is that funny
alright Twitter questions chin from
Taiwan at chin from Taiwan it's funny
name there is so much going on here the
name of the crimes the mug shot
city of Multan Police
five nine Barry Larry Terry that's his
name
because they're three first names
unlawful possession of a wild raccoon no
head like paws bicycle
and the guy's face does he have
shoulders or does his neck just keep
going we got to show this in the video
podcast this guy was arrested for
unlawful possession of a wild raccoon
Wow Wow oh let's do it we haven't before
we'd finish that we have an older right
elder we've got a new elder we have last
one we were last elder we have I think
I'm gonna go to his podcast sue and
Bryan Bryan Callen I'm gonna give him
his pin he's an elder I'm gonna
personally give it to him
so thanks thanks Bryan Callen for being
such a good listener for our podcast but
this is the next Elder and man or woman
it's a guy I think Taylor P at TLP 3 4 2
4 crazy change it went back through
episodes to compile this this is why he
he has it because he went back he went
back through episodes to compiled
comprehensive list compiled a
comprehensive list of all things CUDA
and you can check him out but we will DM
you the the details
you are an elder now and you're invited
to the log cabin when we get it also
we're going to let another person that
supports me tremendously that is a great
guy and loves my podcast and loves my
comedy and looks up to me
Brendan Schaub becomes an elder today so
I'm gonna give him his pin to when I go
do the the fighter and the kid next time
Bryan Callen and Brendon shop you can
congratulate Brendan Shaw for becoming
an elder on on for congratulations so
anyway what else we got here so here's a
good question Valerie Smith at sea crow
we'll be lady Cecropia lady is that
I don't know anyway what clothes did you
bring to Canada in anticipation of the
weather there so I wanted to bring my
heaviest jacket but I didn't I just
brought a hoodie I brought a real
spicy hoodie that had a
camouflage on it was a champion hoodie
hoodie and it was spicy ship and I wore
it the whole time and it's probably very
dirty but whatever I don't get I don't
really smell all that bad I never really
smelled bad but the eye so I
brought this spiciest hoodie dude I
was lighting it up walking everywhere
the snow was melting it was so goddamn
spicy but and then I had this
aviator Jack aviator jacket or whatever
the they call him and on top of it
now I really went outside cuz I'm not
gonna go my mom was like bring a scarf
bring mittens bring your muff so my mom
I'm not gonna go outside I'm not
gonna do all the you know bring
boots bring socks you got to double up
make sure you wear two pants no I'm just
gonna but I've walked a minute I was
outside for at the most I was outside it
was maybe a minute and it was a riot at
the time where you start getting pissed
off so I brought that and pants and
that's it and my Jordans that's about it
Moondog at I am the moon dog hey at
Cresselia what are your thoughts on dog
shows I mean this guy's got a moon dog
this guy loves dog shows
obviously or maybe not but one of my
thoughts on dog shows I mean it's the
richest whitest stupidest
in the world you got a dog it looks fine
guess what it's either cute or not
that's it it's a dog pedigree is a
beautiful cool give it a treat put it on
a goddamn leash
don't walk it around like a
in a field where people are clap
in and guess what those African
dogs they're all ugly take that out of
the category poodles with it all
done nice the out of here
so
gross some of those or you know
a lot of people think oh yeah
what are those Frenchie
with the smashed in faces I can't look
at those dogs without thinking how
miserable they must be they were bred to
breathe up because they look cute
pugs and just always sitting around
like like they're getting choked on
their own face gross the thing wants to
die breed them better Jessie's I Barth
that dr. underscore feel good no I will
not rest until act crystal your comments
on Planet Fitness is lunk alarm first of
all what the I'm looking at the
photo here
lunk alarm lunk noun slang one who
grunts drops weights or judges Rick and
then it here's Ricky is slamming his
weights wearing a bodybuilding tank top
and drinking out a gallon out of a
gallon water jug what a lunk alright
alright Planet Fitness Planet Fitness
you know Planet lunk alarm and then they
hit the lunk alarm it's like a
thing that you can press I would like it
if I only would think this is okay if
you could hit it and it goes ahh
bar and people in uniforms come and
remove you we have another lung we need
to we need we need gas your belongings
you need to leave
we'll get your has water I
hate when people break I've talked about
this before when you people I've got a
gallon jugs working out like bring a
bottle bring a bottle or bring
one of those you know but where
does it stop though the making
it nice making the making the the
environment having to think about it
like I saw vegan four periods they have
vegan cups where you just it's reusable
you put it in your how do I say a
politically correct hatchet wound you
put it in your fried butterfly and you
what you bleed in it out of your
walled up used never mind
so gross and and you bleed in it and
then when you bleed in it you empty it
and you wash it out I mean you put it
back where does it stop huh this blood
coming out ship bottom how about this
instead of that Dhoni
don't eat meat or don't or we bring a
fork to a restaurant or some herb you
know don't use a plastic fork or
whatever where does it stop that's the
same thing as the old grandpa this
handkerchief and then blowing his nose
in the handkerchief and then putting it
in the pocket ah you got snot in
your blazer now I'll wash it I'll wash
it later and then use it again use a
Kleenex use
neck's you know that's you know
what's grosser than that one thing one
things grosser than that one thing and
one thing only I could ask him how he
wants each cut of his body to be done
and label it for him with a black marker
YUM dude it's funny out of context but
it is not funny in context if you think
about it Jesus Christ going to hell uh
whatever you're all coming with me all
right all right that's I think that's it
that's good for today yeah all right you
guys was a great one there was a long
one
we had some ads here so I was good
thanks for sticking with me you guys
what's up first of all get the Chris
D'Elia app if you got it or not
got to do that I put other on there
that I don't put any other places any
other places on social media so but this
is the thing for the first leg of the
new tour announced today Follow the
Leader the tickets go on sale to the
general public on Friday on Friday buy
tickets on Chris D'Elia calm I'm going
to Tallahassee Orlando Charleston
Pittsburgh Dayton Huntsville Nashville
Denver Boise Cleveland and I'm adding
other ones subscribe to the YouTube
channel and rate and review the show it
really helps if you are a true baby it
really helps us do that you know because
I'm not gonna do this if I keep it it
doesn't keep growing that's what happens
with businesses and cults the same thing
if it's not grown if you're not growing
you're dying watch my specials on
Netflix and video episodes go up
Tuesday's or Wednesday so be on the
lookout for that square cache have you
switched yet
download the free square cash app into
rewards code Congrats get $5 give $5 -
times up
and get it for iOS or Android now and
blue apron check out this with menu and
get your $30 off with free shipping at
blue apron
[Music]